vous voulez vendre le manuscrit original
de condorcet et vous avez réussi à
réunir une foule d'acheteurs potentiels
qu'elle enchères vaut-il mieux utiliser
alors bien sûr il ya l'enchère classique
où chaque acheteur annonce un prix plus
élevé que le dernier plat annoncée mais
il a aussi tout plein d'autres enchères
imaginables comme le cher au second prix
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode précédent
où chacun annonce un prix et le bien est
vendu au plus offrant aux prix annoncés
par le second plus offrant mais c'est
pas tout il ya encore plein d'autres
enchères et pour déterminer quelle est
la meilleure enchère je vous invite à en
découvrir d'autres
en 1637 les néerlandais découvre avec
émerveillement latulippe très rapidement
posséder une tulipe devient une
distinction sociale remarquer de sorte
que les néerlandais se les arrachent
c'est la tulipomanie une bulbes de
tulipes prend des valeurs déraisonnable
et parfois même s'échangent est
contraint de manoir les vendeurs sont
alors débordé face à des hordes
d'acheteurs déchaînés il leur faut une
enchère rapide et efficace c'est là
qu'ils en vendront cher à la
néerlandaise
le vendeur commence par annoncer un prix
très élevé qu'il descend au fur à mesure
jusqu'à ce qu'un acheteur se manifeste
alors cette enchère néerlandaise qu'en
pensez vous au japon l'exact opposé fut
souvent utilisés autrement dit le
vendeur commence à un prix très bas et
les acheteurs sont initialement tous
debout dès que le prix est trop élevé
pour un acheteur potentiel
l'acheteur potentiel ça soit le dernier
debout canio longchair et achète le bien
au dernier prix annoncé par le vendeur
l'enchère à la japonaise et anne meyer
clan chars la néerlandaise jusque là on
a vu que des enchères en temps réel dans
le feu de l'action
tous les acheteurs potentiels doivent
alors être présents en même temps il est
peut-être plus simple alors de faire
participer les acheteurs via des lettres
fermé et ensuite de vendre le bien à
l'acheteur dont le prix écrit est le
plus élevé au prix qu'il a écrit ils
gagnent tant par rapport au cas où les
acheteurs participe activement à
l'enchère et quid de méthodes
radicalement différente
jusque là toutes les anciens repose
finalement plus ou moins sur le même
principe mais tant qu'à faire on peut
proposer des règles beaucoup plus
bizarroïde par exemple on peut dire à
chaque acheteur d'écrire un prix qu'il
paiera quoi qu'il arrive que le bien lui
soit attribué non le bien ira ensuite à
l'acheteur qui a écrit le plus grand
prix alors une idée de quelle est la
meilleure enchère possible bon la
réponse est loin d'être évidente
notamment parce que les comportements
des vrais acheteurs sont pas toujours
super rationnelle les bon de rappeler
que nous avons des crétins de cerveau
qui serions très mal notre hygiène
mentale et n'arrivons pas à penser
outside the box un peu comme si on avait
la tronche en biais mais supposons pour
aujourd'hui que l'enchère soit à très
gros enjeu les participants ont été
sélectionnés par leur patron pour leur
discernement et que les patrons laurent
clairement fixé un budget limite pour
l'acquisition du bien ou dit plus
simplement supposons que les
participants soient rationnel dans ce
cadre mathématiques plus restreint
quelle est la meilleure enchère parmi
celles que l'on a vues et bien de façon
surprenante en 1981
l'économiste et mathématicien rogers
meyerson à
prouver que toutes les enchères que l'on
vient de voir sont en fait équivalente
plus précisément meyerson approuvé le
théorème dit d'équivalence des revenus
toutes les enchères qui vende le bien à
celui qui lui attribuent la plus grande
valeur gagne en moyenne l'équilibré de
nash le même revenu alors derrière ce
théorème il a quand même pas mal
d'hypothèses qui ne sont pas toujours
hyper réaliste en particulier mason
suppose que les différents acheteurs
sont neutres au risque or on a vu dans
l'épisode 12 que cette hypothèse est
incompatible avec le fait qu'aucun
d'entre nous n'est prêt à payer des
milliards pour jouer au jeu du paradoxe
de saint pétersbourg soit mais supposons
pour l'instant et pour simplifier que
les hypothèses de mason sont bien
vérifier est ce à dire que toutes les
enchères reviennent au même
eh bien non la magnifique découverte de
mason qui lui fera gagner le prix nobel
du 2007 c'est que bien souvent on peut
faire mieux et pour ce faire il faut
s'autoriser à ne pas vendre le bien au
plus offrant autrement dit pour
maximiser ses gains un vendeur devra
parfois refuser de vendre le bien même
si les prix annoncés par les acheteurs
lui garantissent un profit important ou
encore un vendeur devra parfois vendre
le bien est quelqu'un qui n'est pas le
plus offrant
même si le vendeur aurait gagné plus
qu'en vendant ce bien au plus offrant
bizarre tout ça pour comprendre comment
meyerson a pu en arriver à cette
conclusion étonnante
il faut bien voir que les enchères et
les négociations c'est un peu comme le
poker dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 15
le gros problème c'est l'incomplétude de
l'information le vendeur ne sais pas ce
que les acheteurs sont vraiment prêts à
payer face aussi lié en pratique
notamment parce qu'ils ont sans doute vu
passer beaucoup d'acheteurs
les vendeurs ont quand même une idée de
ce que les acheteurs sont probablement
prêt à payer un passionné de match
serait sans doute pas à payer quelques
dizaines d'euros pour les manuscrits de
confort c'est peut-être même quelques
centaines d'euros
mais sans doute pas des millions
notamment parce qu'un passionné de maths
c'est pas souvent milieu
encore que il ya des exceptions genre
ceux qui ont basculé dans la finance
pour devenir milliardaire les vendeurs
ont donc une idée des préférences des
acheteurs ont dit que les vendeurs ont
des croyances bayésienne sur ce que les
acheteurs sont prêts à payer
alors pour les matheux parmi vous cette
croyance bayésienne est une loi de
probabilité sur les budgets limites que
se fixent les acheteurs et on accuse
également grand effet petit théâtre les
fonctions de répartition et de densité
de cette fois de probabilités et bientôt
façon cruciale dans le modèle de
meilleur sommes devenus standards en
économie ce qui intéresse vraiment le
vendeur c'est son espérance de gain
c'est à dire ce qu'ils gagneraient en
moyenne en répétant l'enchère avec des
acheteurs différents et si chacun des
acheteurs étaient conformes à la
croyance bayésienne bon alors ça c'est
pas tout à fait la bonne interprétation
des croyances parisienne et fouet
qu'elle freine un peu plus ce temps de
vous parler de ses croyances bayésienne
et il faudrait a sans doute tout un
bouquin pour aborder tout ça
quoi qu'il en soit dans notre cas
d'enchères si le vendeur cherchent à
maximiser son espérance de gain il va
lui falloir accepter de perdre un peu
parfois pour gagner beaucoup d'autres
fois et ça c'est précisément ce qu'a
conclu au german personne en 1981 mais
ailleurs sonne prouve que les vendeurs y
gagne à fixer un prix dits de réserve
c'est à dire en deçà duquel les vendeurs
ne vendrons pas et de façon cruciale ce
prix de réserve ne dépend absolument pas
de la valeur intrinsèque du bien ou de
son coût de fabrication
ce prix de réserve dépend uniquement de
la créance bayésienne du vent dehors sur
ce que les acheteurs sont prêts à payer
pour les matheux parmi vous déterminer
le prix de réserve correspond à résoudre
l'équation qui est possible et ça ça a
une conséquence que beaucoup d'entre
vous vont trouver malsaine pour
maximiser ses gains un vendeur a tout
intérêt à adapter le prix de réserve à
ce qu'ils croient que l'acheteur est
prêt à payer autrement dit pour
maximiser ses gains un vendeur doigt
discriminé ses acheteurs potentiels et
ça si vous êtes déjà allé au maroc au
vietnam chaussures vous l'avez dit
surtout si vous êtes entré dans un
magasin en mode gros touristes européens
de base il vous sera alors virtuellement
impossible de négocier un prix
comparable à ce que les locaux bay pire
encore au maximiser ses gains un
acheteur doit organiser une bataille à
distance entre acheteurs potentiels en
se permettant de vendre au moins offrant
s'ils pensent que le plus offrant
annonce des prix qui sont très en deçà
de ce qui est vraiment prêt à payer
donc si vous constatez que vous payez
beaucoup trop cher par rapport aux
locaux sachez que ce n'est sans doute
pas parce que vous n'avez aucun talent
de négociation et ce n'est pas non plus
parce que les locaux sont des xénophobes
qui déteste les touristes c'est tout
simplement parce que les vendeurs ou une
croyance bayésienne parfaitement
justifiable et justifiée en le fait
qu'un touriste européen est prêt à payer
plus cher pour un bien car locales et
parce que les vendeurs applique sans
doute sans le savoir une enchère proche
de celle de meilleur jeune
ça nous amène un gros problème de
société et oui parce que l'enchère de
meyerson elle est discriminatoire
alors oui je sais discriminer c'est pas
bien et tout ça mais il faut bien voir
qu'en l'absence de légifération
l'enchère de mason combinée à la loi des
marchés dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 9
montre que la discrimination sera
inéluctable mais ce n'est pas une
opinion qui exprime là c'est une
conséquence d'un modèle mathématique qui
semble assez pertinent pour décrire la
réalité alors dans le cas de recherche
de meilleurs sonne il s'agit d'une
discrimination qui est pas forcément
choquant puisque ceux qui sont
défavorisés sont a priori ceux qui sont
prêts à payer plus encore que si vous
avez le malheur d'être un pauvre avec
une tête de riches
vous allez en fait être très défavorisé
par l'enchère de meilleur sort mais on
peut avoir des cas plus contreverse où
les preneurs de décisions tout intérêt à
se reposer sur des créances bayésienne
justifiable est justifié pour
discriminer ceux qui sont directement
affectées par les décisions alors on
pourra se demander si des croyances
justifier à les justifier ça existe est
bon la réponse est clairement oui et
pour ça je vous raconte l'excellente
vidéo de dirt idéologie sur le racisme
alors certes dans certains cas on peut
peut-être compter sur les valeurs
éthiques de preneurs de décision pour ne
pas discriminer
mais si les pressions à suivre les
incentives sont trop fortes comme ça
peut être le cas par exemple en période
de crise alors en l'absence de
légifération et de contrôle il faut
s'attendre à ce que les décisions prises
soient discriminatoire des enfants n'a
parlé du principe de révélation et je
vous avais donné un peu les formules
mathématiques à un moment à l'image et
cédric paix a vu qu'il y avait une
énorme coquille dans mes mathématiques
donc bien vu de sa part et là j'ai envie
de pousser un petit coup de gueule
contre youtube qui depuis quelques mois
à désactiver les annotations et du coup
je suis pas capable de corriger ce que
j'ai écrit ça ça m'embête vraiment qu'il
ya quelqu'un parmi vous qui travaillez
youtube s'il vous plaît permettez moi de
faire quelque chose pour que y'a pas
cette erreur qui traînent encore dans ma
vidéo
s'il vous plaît mathieu perreault 20 là
bas john et alexandre martin demande si
l'enchère au second prix favorise
vraiment donner à toutes et à tous
il ya une peluche à vendre que le
premier acheteur à 10,1 euros et qu'on
veut vraiment on pourrait dire tout de
suite après 1 millions d'euros et bas
prix personne ne va surenchérir sur nous
sauf que dans l'enchère au second prix
est bien tous les plis compter en
particulier il n'y a pas de raison de
s'interdire d'annoncer des prix qui sont
pas le plus haut prix en particulier un
troisième acheteur pourra dire ce qu'il
est vraiment prêt à acheter pour la
peluche peut-être qu'il est prêt à payer
1000 euros pour cette peluche parce
qu'il est vraiment fan de cette peluche
à ce moment là celui qui vient
d'annoncer un million d'euros il va
devoir payer 1000 euros pour la peluche
alors qu'il la voulait peut-être pas
forcément est en fait c'est parce que
chaque acheteur veut éviter de se
retrouver dans une situation où il doit
payer un second prix qui en fait plus
élevé que ce qu'il est vraiment prêt à
payer que si vous y réfléchissez
chacun a vraiment intérêt à annoncer
uniquement un seul prix et ce prix là et
le prix qu'il est vraiment prêt à payer
pour acquérir le bien et la vente âge de
faire cela c'est qu'on peut expédier
beaucoup plus rapidement les hanches art
parce que bon les enchères au premier
prix ça peut durer potentiellement si
les gens à voir centime par centime ça
peut durer une éternité
l'arrosage de l'enchère au second prix
bas c'est que tout le monde a intérêt à
annoncer directement ce qui est vraiment
prêt à payer et en particulier variante
d'un truc qui serait dit à voix haute ce
sera juste d'écrire sur un bout de
papier chacun écrit là le montant qu'il
ait frappé et puis si on met tout ça
dans une boîte puis on collecte tous les
bulletins en gros puis on regarde dans
l'urne
quel est le plus haut montant est le
second plus haut montant et à partir de
ça on veut bien aux plus offrants aux
prix annoncés par le second plus au
froid et ça ça me permettent d'adresser
à la question de théaux pointe amis ce
qu'ils nous demandent aussi le principe
de révélations ne revient pas d'une
certaine manière à institutionnaliser
les comportements immoraux d'une
certaine manière oui ce sera le cas mais
ce sera le cas à l'intérieur d'un
algorithme dont on n'est pas obligé de
regarder ce qui se passe et en
particulier on peut faire en sorte que
personne ne soit au courant de ce qui
s'est passé dans la boîte du point de
vue de l'extérieur tout ce qu'on voit
c'est des participants qui doivent
donner des données à l'algorithme
d'algorithmes tourne et retourne un
résultat et c'est typiquement le cas de
l'enchère au second prix en fait chacun
donne une donnée qui est ce qui est
vraiment prépayées l'intérieur de l'algo
et il peut avoir une simulation de
l'enchère au premier clic classique où
chacun va surenchérir centime par
centime
et puis quand l'enchère fini c'est un
certain résultat il correspond à vendre
le bien une certaine personne
certains prix c'est tout ça c'est simulé
à l'inter de l'égoïsme mais du point de
vue extérieur tout ce qui nous intéresse
c'est le résultat final est tout ce que
l'on voit c'est que le bien est vendu à
telle personne au prix du second plus
offrant qui est égal à t-elle sol est en
partie tuer tous les comportements
immoraux qui se sont passés à
l'intérieur de l'algorithme finalement
on déconne et sera même pas ça amène
aussi à la très bonne question des
radicales qui demande du coup est ce que
si on applique vraiment le principe de
révélations à l'enchère au premier prix
on devrait pas vendre le bien au plus
offrant au prix du second plus offrant
plus une unité négligeable plus un
centime ou plus
epsilon et ben en fait oui ça serait ça
techniquement si on applique vraiment le
principe de révélations à l'enchère au
premier prime devra obtenir un truc plus
epsilon après bayonne aussi petit qu'on
veut du coup et tendre vers zéro et on
obtient du coup l'enchère 2vic ray qui
consiste à vendre au second prix plus et
pilonnent ou ips youn est égal à zéro
enfin d'aral salle réagit à ce que
j'avais dit sur le marché de
l'électricité californien où j'avais dit
que c'était une très mauvaise idée
d'avoir des régulations partielle de ce
marché et du coup de bol ça lui demande
si il ya des cas où la dérégulation est
une bonne idée
eh bien il ya plein de chercheurs qui se
sont intéressés à cette question en
particulier le prix nobel d'économie
jean tirole qui s'intéressait à la
dérégulation de beaucoup de marché et ce
qui ressort du travail de jean tirole
c'est que ça dépend beaucoup beaucoup
des démarches et des cas du contexte d
incentive de propriété en fait du marché
et il est très très très important de
réfléchir en fonction du marché
pour certains marchés la dérégulation
peut très bien marcher pour certains
marchés ça peut être une catastrophe et
il ya vraiment une étude économique des
acteurs en jeu et des propriétés du
marché à faire pour pouvoir déterminer
dans quelle situation c'est bénéfique
dans quelle situation ça peut être
catastrophique en particulier les
réponses de jean tirole sont très nuancé
c'est pas juste a un truc au milieu
marche bien en général le truc au milieu
en fait il peut être encore plus
catastrophique que la dérégulation
totale que là
l'augmentation totale et dans le cas du
marché de l'électricité california la
dérégulation partiel fait que parce que
vraiment catastrophique la solution du
milieu là était vraiment catastrophique
bref sur la question de la dérégulation
des marchés
il me semble que c'est une question très
très économique qui demande beaucoup d
expertise et en particulier caricature
que l'on voit souvent dans le paysage
politique du genre il faut t'il 12 et
régulé où il faut tout régulé sont
souvent pas du tout conforme à la
recherche en tout cas en économie
encore une fois j'ai envie de dire qu'il
faut faire vraiment gaffiot liane
politique qui est en nous lorsque l'on
parle de problèmes un peu idéologique
comme cela
souvent les bonnes réponses sont plus
subtiles que le clivage classique qui
ont peu dépeindre dans le paysage
politique
elle espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo alors dans cette vidéo on a parlé
de comment maximiser les gains du
vendeur on peut se poser une autre
question comment est ce qu'on peut faire
des enchères qui corresponde a
finalement donné les biens à ceux qui
demande le plus qu'ils en veulent le
plus et ça ça correspond à maximiser une
espèce de bien-être social et c'est en
fait exactement ce qui arrive à faire le
mécanisme du bcg dont on parlera dans le
prochain épisode pour vie créée car
quelques robes et ce mécanisme a le bon
goût d'être non seulement socialement
optimale mais également une sent-il
compatibles si vous avez aimé cet
épisode penser à le l'ikea le
commentaire de partage et pensez à vous
abonner pas manquer les futurs épisodes
merci au type power dont et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois